[Music]
now a lot of you watch this show and it
feels like and Jason you back me up on
this but you watch this show and it
feels like a lot of us are learning
about female anatomy from the show
there's a lot of people characters
lecturing lecturing each other teaching
each other is that fair to say I still
don't know what I'm doing when it when
it comes when it comes to the female
anatomy or yeah my wife it's not my baby
[Laughter]
it's an actor baby oh we hired a baby to
play my baby when the first season you
had to help Natasha
with a scene and it was what area how do
you yes I did there's no Coke I'm
deafening this story out of you that's
how she talks about everything very fast
I would say deliria how do you cuz of
course you're gonna come to me for that
and I said this is how you look for the
car keys look for the car keys Judy
Garland look for the car keys the credit
car keys Judy Garland Joan Crawford
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah this really family show this isn't
gonna air now waiting for my consultant
have you noticed have you noticed an
uptick in female attention since you
started appearing on the show Jonas
Brother are you kidding yeah seriously
mix comes into the dressing room we had
not met we've done an entire season and
none of us have met Biggs right and so
I'm like he comes in my room and he goes
so it's great to meet you blah blah blah
blah you get a lot of I was like like I
need a hit show to get straight boy
[Applause]
[Applause]
how's innocent days of these shows where
people would just do an Irish jig
simpler wholesome you got
you